wright
let's get started a welcome to the
workshop production
luigi so my name is marc working at
briefly developing data so that also details
about beta data engineering and a bit of
software engineering want to talk about
interactive data science interactive
model development and how we can
basically transform  development workflow
transformer model web like
interactivemedia allows introduction to
building workflows in the tourist
history dreamliner development offers
the version configuration
automatically different in images according to josef
schumpeter notebooks it is the peak in st
this time in the center smolin like bild.de
word no in first place
production radio.de model interactive
one as important products
okay this is a form of the tutti frutti
cone competition features for down to
climb are bananas new models the
imports
ignore little bit of the texter table
the output but and it is your last
little bit interface about the  half
douglas boss banana si  nd lemons here
the trailer testing day for example from
google body of the date via the simple
command so far the data systems is as
soon as part of database of data
training personals solutions
because the imports received here and the
bad case of solution field the
image the generator wide
here as well as not so much
anymore anymore as well as have them and different
angle photos from different angels
different no software often
widener cent to online zorn des taste giants
that we can keep our image data
generated simply because we don't have
to  do is here to basics generated
function after we have any parameters of
patches customers with the 1
but will half patches here make a
comeback there it does
max peter mohr explorer tory analysis
now the classic the balance
is exactly the topic and on the
glass stage  the process is times on board
back
the booklets glasses here you can now
learn and banana douglas indices the
mount the software  distinct class
so far so good jeffers looking at
something that any model should
principality thinks when he attaches stars
is the planning of the nice but for my
respect is often a good performance bot
a smarter den erwin net.de first to
find something to do something  in the
bases classification, whether in civilian
by on the offensive whether a computer
vision located the great image
processing library bridges open source
at inter racing you need you we need
for computer vision of social media
as well as for you start building and the
machine learning model image  something's
so easy way you can test agenda knows how
to one of my first model ist gut
bananas annie award des model is doing
usd after
the number is the function of the model
of different parameters families no
top model samuel von your local machine
and production model is full  image
processing
[music]
bananas is not an apple today you won't
be able to be used as much anymore but
for papers now how costs  it
begs present last year that the
short duration models in the hollow
computer vision of google and when you
will never be a harmless now conc
is often managers activator the service
because it's my life filter generated
images 11 generations internet here
comes before kernels is simple  switcher
perform
basically in the back cooperation of the
major djs in this major title
the idea of ​​the josef filter
the indian performer the sliding window was
repeatedly burdened picture this day generate new
value through the pictures i took an
opentv people basics in india in the end
plates of the holding  and well thought
of inputs the dance teacher dance layer is
basically classics network as
here the correction glases end its search
and mobility from banana are the higher
tempo betty hor rangers instead of
binary metric out of the tens of law
with ratings of the basic i have  to just
thought we have a spec ops validation
steps the kit in my box in our
exp  ertise and interactive development we
live djs live one which then follows the us top
diplomat discussion on from the
max kohr with
google across a lot of time bioware
google is because the republic 100 levels
erbach must also be open
on the most of the company sa  do i
really liked this idea essent company
software engineering prospective
basically ice days the software engineer
from mad max and complexity and
applications of education is made in the
jupiter notebooks pc notebook davis jr
notebook
[Music]
the notebook quality quality
invests the paper from google to
peoples  automation valley data quality
on the model and sword how much of it
is automatic don't think about it
integration testing the sun testing
system works with the lost thing about
how much data the process vegas
information but it's not collect
together burn notice that we don  't know
how long xfx am things motives
continuous integration continuous
deployment the monitoring automation  and
health care take some kind of processing
unit develop pipelines or with luigi
pipelines are for long running casting
is luigi basically there is support
for the key of different technologies of
what kind of tools are you you sing for
data center toolkit models of technology
is on  data software the idea the picture
is last
how to compose this pipelines workflow
in basic i have sex with the stars
results and dependency tasci pansy basic
wild target of disasters parameters
closely easy here waiting des pink
you might have seen this here waiting
des pink currently decides  is the
pitching path to data centers example
workflow from script as simple as
hated
luigi vor in basic conjunction with you
because you tube is so complex end
point of service get connected services
for everybody knows what love is
distributed file system die jupiter
scheme of distributed systems  cfs
in wanheim secret of what cars were
volksaltar suite oracle database  parked
cars and sony look some children's theater
big part the igad the it daughter is now waiting for
your third city music for you
is disco drive table target with simply
checks is the table for you done the
table for you texprocess here is
running that there it often framework that
makes you use of directors of secure an
end or moscow started in paris a
diss tracks haye is that one is here
paradise is that one about the
hardship of the day here so the local holidays
theater stars last external
programmers of the
latter clubs of the data centers the
aixtron  is how extracts data one touch
as well as the to create processing
processing configuration effort
republic of the car because we are you
sing image data base line welsh
allstars easy going to value add water
to me of the luxor temple war venture
last today is a day since time and
became this  Judgment is the pending
form knows the luxury you anymore
imagine this my hand so anniversary model
super smart  data scientist
jorgos kaminis tenant dem production operations team
ok picture the script how can you
feel a change in whatever you like to
car rents first day but loudly
decked out tick evaluates farmstead
ask it meets des base line to compare
ends favorite trend model at sony
zur  configuration benito expected to
download the data and basslines of the data
training with the data and elite
configuration as well as your lot of
independence yourself a lot of work and
probably the first how to do it from abbas
experience that i can build discounting
sin do it
from dead canned  heat like
letting
petereit customers sit okay let's go sports we
have to download the day that used in
cologne is in our inner image right here
is the window location
tipping the location currently gets
nobody does it come from how
either you take over the portal  talking
about targets and the talking about
outputs download is download in luigi
is object oriented so simple erich
fr  omm from the external program cars and the
only two to implement u2 functions in
python so last here as the
parameters the parameter is a
parameter the full
version of the next monday just called to say we call it a
sad
august in the gold tactile city usa
sometimes we  be little bit an complex
you can get more flexible
the parameter four if the output is
but local target with simply red the
output india if the stars is sex it
probably that one exists program arx
easy going over half here is the
url as forms film  displays url
now took inter version on the often on
the dayton boots here
minute sorry so ringbeck like a reduce
the dionysus view structures men
now in science and if you like you can
make it parameter
the cool so the sourkrauts are the
jupiter notebook online on xing  this is
the download is an data check in is it
data access and probably not be
downloaded als left continue cool and
small caps am glas last war test
gen  au we still have internet
download since june apple is building this hayo in
waikiki luigi my husbands module this
is the training pipeline so that to tell
you have the code in the deep fall
should the racing to show you and i have
to spies the third game to motto show  so
now it is said in the code that you
can t course about global import if i
ask you here a discussant wall presents
pansy is a counter and asset justice
working to get you sing days
luigi nonos has the is original kfor the
session on the data center  storage
system we can check the image here
the departure is in the temporary as
folder because the next big thing is
how does it know little to expect
skf process in the export is the
download how does the input targetbase
how get the way back the  ost praise is
he likes to grab is the stylish folder
but we want a complete party
basic benefits next most of the time you
don't have to touch any password saver
you then sit jugendref  erentin putt
putt so you don t know what love is like
we have the virgin return of the output the
output is the in port elizabeth
ran to the buttons of torture and the
choice of the world university ranking of
roja doing the path to be executed ok
dies war  as an external program fits yes
what not meant for fighting
betweenliebenau is mini tower configuration on
board sz is okay it then went on
with is dj set matic person at simply
you is an extract configured that you
opel target create puyol directory that
you need for  example ilike
virgin-cosworth
[music]
the flexible system for image processing
nukem basic wi fi parameter uk parameter
interest ask a werst basically what
you can do is simple parameters under
the last parameter utilities to create
new things delete your hits from 100 the
unis in  the ivorian theory the iss
the
it is the third set key with
workstation
that is outside like costs makes it makes
it at least young testival like the
the nation will dip the base line into the
explorer torriani will be at the celebration on
the notebook portfolio baseline
validation samuel embedded automation
inc usability about the ostel pretty nice
because it's like the base line
validation what comes out and new opel
target that's a bit opel  target
is basically jason fall containing the
certain ok space education and
interesting
in mean the pending and confused the
pending and extract enter key
validation authority reference to all of
this information
the extract datacenter configuration so
in order to base flying validation of
the date of course  configuration of
image processing now they act
like they are extra the case or directly
after the happy ending the advance or
download the problem download version 2
6 was released a statement saying goes
back face of the form of fact so
the ports also of the baseline valley
dacian and  if you put into your it
simple luigi colani filius des command
in jork s  erver venue trainer new model
and for example you want to have fun
configuration you already have des
automation and instead of base line
validation uk allstars obediently to the
top models lines of code interview
die bot google voice from you and i get
di tobia or 40 little  bit of
hot now not do transition jol
notebook code inter arranged like
cosmos of the time the other side of
news corp is so what is it here this
tattoo that is the of the single source of
thieves notebook is enemy research with
toy story or single source of  new
york ca
the booklets baseline validation
configuration with contentxxl another
object
like you but baseline security check
offers before but now is basically
samuel is only now not version
trading. de versions of the base station
is not a call of the model simply
die fans hits  the same thing to do it pc
notebook was that is the configuration
and raid configuration expect that you
can use self document  is targeting mother
access to use model architect otto
change and think city train a model here
either save the full model for trend
model end tempo des parameters here
[music]
station
so now but then just a little bit
paranoid has a check on the  model
exists exists innovation session
band and is already tens of service
suite next topmodel
the evaluation fight why people
want so little bit more complex to do is
you want to check out our model is the
heroine configuration people image
processing baby that as a reflex to the
stars  like executed
and yes you can easily ghetto the
evaluation cool stuff kamps the
evaluation the bassline evaluation were
the evaluation before the model and
[music]
security model is base layer basic save
the result of men like born to know
what happens
[music]
bauer taskforce  fully shutdown
industries here of the program lux ps because
the agenda of the problem luxx sesg
because the world as we just ask is missing
de  r sense exception
the equity options and 5 is painter because
the academy of zero point 95 as well as the
have one thing that google really wanted
validate the motto quality so that it is
still implemented funny how
implemented final
result of the targeted access for
decision model in its  late but is
different data station of the pipeline
pipes downloaded new day that and it
starts the holding and the new day that
again the train the new model to this
news of the world
the historic house phase of the
baseline validation what you
expected in conficker either sexual  valuator
model and that looks good luck new model
virtue like you are here
oh dear have the evaluation in viral to
develop text sits douglas douglas
problem so discussion of the celebration is the
start of the halo kids at this just
starting stack sporting the cross on so
this north  implemented implementation
111 fetched pipeline is lets and to
run lines of code becomes too complex for you  e
easy to handle already a software
engineering perspective and it data
center testing is like a picture
also in uk deployments ok blue green
deployments pre-dancer flow models for
ever tried to deserve means of transport in
riehl environment only praise things
applications holds the mortgage builds
trading what kind  of [ __ ] is indian
dancers airport have to talk about
memory so and if you have not storage
from model have the booklets tk 4.5
gigabytes of waiting to your love flow
and ride service google system platform
the play offs end days and serve the
music experience orie make  some
experience with stable almost endless
irving and is nothing bit in the big
pictures of service
the hess model version in logistics bad
modeling policies meaning you can tell
tale of surfing and startup week for the
last four versions of you get new york
to the pro version one  two three four
and the city of new models
the future motto simply basic changer
services to the new model ste  p by step
zeftera problems and human services inc
new york new model known the oled
model joanna the new model and ion
top model now to the people a kilo
from one stop or into you into automation
your money to infrastructure recording
to google paypal
latter fraud des  sensors irving is
heidi extensible but it s extensive good
in c++ so 400 so good ins plus
you can stay with the baseballs simply
preisdruck ab models in certain before the
brit something did so let's dance of
surfing model iris evaluate export award
a serien hier ist tänzer  floss
höring is thoroughly watching in the
folder service either section euro which,
according to google ex-model virgin racing,
prohibits
not that easy and not that they
documented autoexport carrasco into the net
because softlayer around the new health
model eustace of loving you is most on
the problem sees  he is in production model
picture on the model it can
dancer info info input and dancer before
output and source for the c  are of
scotland the output dancers on the
covers motto and what's happening here
ist am pilze google potthoff keeps
lot of time objectives of laws irving
ist because he used the media pc user
spirit of civilization and the city of
the terms of service baseball puderbach
for everything  that you better
communications i realize in the plaster from the
team racing series in vlotho va
hubert the spot raid before impotent
output of the political signature here
predictions bfd input output mass with sermon
take away simply telling tens of
surfing what kind of interface pours
providing model view sermon interfaces
flexible  interface
[music]
the optimal
so the model version here would be
export prospects need is one because
the model version is an export park
and without specific interests part
is here we are using the stance of the
dead end how you eat how basic i used to
meter graf  out of recession that mean it
means everything the youtube not rid
of che  ckitout how free this is
somehow important for training for
graf will be able to execute how much
the ticket definition the critics of
this hobby putting the safe of the fall
out party saves already into a tense of
low involvement design automatic
basic which continues deployment of sense
of low  models models and is recovered big
pictures gated workflow in ticino is
via battle.net the fine as on an
automatic deployment of the model on
the new model virgin into the one and
the big picture
you can use of surfing you can use
spark machine learning pipelines  you can
use nld whatever you like as soon as you
have a propos export function from model
export to your environment health it
looks you already have really nice
geldautomat process to play sees diploma
models automatically finally all that i
got a lot of google topix coverage
operations  team will love you might have
plenty minute running
when a close to die and because we're
doing is like parameters  in parameter
taken from parameter matthau the des look
in the deeper technology is anyone who
i want to show you one one more
technology one more task implementation
and we like that makes you really useful
for peace park and the world's best
price park before the flames so spec  ops
survival song because second job
cooperation have to take the veils from
pfizer also in the package the playoffs on the
way in which makes denyo holt eisbar
class e environment technos tick
nordeck funny environment the commuters
to the article clusters in the class i
have to take that everything is
distributed  politics racing louis james
park fits so the price bad as me to
execute price barcode directly in milow kitas
kosovo is simple target i also know the
eur loud core from speed
autotage the wm test output and in the
middle you can only radios park job
and you can direct ico the spark should
now be here in because the ennahda party
strange days album we can in harrislee
is me egg  n example
[music]
basic i with spinning from classic night
running casting six of data and
branding of the skate night in the morning
vietnam offers know how can you spinner
cluster dynamics bath hathaway sam
resources and half of the way to
the taste resources is
wilfried  stephan handl therapy
automatic manager resources and besides
you look into the look into the database
config files and context how intense
session so that it is hollow computation
here running on your smart laster and you
can make it right here
put your code internet feil the reference
des  fire you started from me still
running in spa state park jobs where you
have to haendels anpasst around the trees and
whatever it can be done everything i do
i do and as simple as exporting tens of
london and chose a beauty and the last
dance for some  time for the space age of
the water show is have you ever came
across the still of filling so johanning
data injection pipeline every day 26
providers vo  n web site at work you have
to the killings of us custom acts so
lures the machine were
linked to the bag we just word have a
console and have to take that your data
is consistent the concert in days back
after that we are
finally on the news  .de this is eh
csu meanwhile the third
heft attacks skip the x1 gives tefaf not that would
have you can skip to do that we can skip
to you have disabled beck philipp
mechanisms inside your pipeline the
today changes can really having to
handle
anything you anymore  end were were
interviewed isailovic is quite jim press
event with framework now close to flow
infor crm in you can use a lot of the
interview you can't on the covers
[applause]
[music]
this time  on the computer
yes of the tournament which is used for example
in interviews peters said you can use also
the penan you america and execute
so what you do is you can simply lupo
wahlvolks ampel the directory models and
y  et another set had to butt bidding war
number of the new york post online know
what you can forget perversen new haven
evaluation perversen and if one is not
working offenders are gettorfer discount
rises
this events of documents
now will update the expect a website
to clean code little bit but  you will
get everything in the abstract exactly
der will be a link to the depository
Hoffenheims model version that went to
control of your web framework station
das do it profi fail better safe for you
don't run on framework that you're dead
luigis des  deaths especially in the cinemas
environment and really hard luigi 1000
provide you any password it the only
what you can except you are obediently here
conversions pursued executed
that was s most of you can use output
open
the cost of the tomic operation is
your existence exista voice  of cars when
you have to update the data access to
have a problem
visual web service al sudani is now
the birth of the luigi server  totally
prebuilt tanks is part of the
bar today from the history options it in
the logic configuration day keeps on the
history of your tasks delete develop
[music]
evaluate perfectly
an update an phantasy spending could
racing is done so let's go to evaluate
the get  is yes that you like some
sorts okay so here you say what is
basically depending on information
download the expected to execute the
least task of the not then something extra
checking did you expect that never goes
to download the end of day to
download
only the first one  window target filed
under performance important to say ist
the visualization luigi ist davis basic
i have no central saint just get you
your tasks using comments basically
notifier luigi server what's going on
this way basically mit autochips ist
tasci running for certain parameters so
if you try to  first run the party
with the same parameters at the same time
it blog from systems
apa/red execution and to run so  still the
thing is now picture by willy brandt on
the machine were the booty product
volksparks from noon yes the
pipeline is problems long josef jva
sloning job running and that was great
red boss the intention prepares night for
use dancer flow the plans
basically de projet  because of scale
model into obedient google cloud
platform is with her total luigi lux
and change documents version bradley
will luigi pira continues gives people
and live world of change something and
a jeans short code execution would be
displayed container in schinkels
this is basically doubled by apple
double container luigi inside the code
in the architect antoine de luigi inside
because as long as you papa billy
top referent server des connected to
survive the visual station the car was
this video dult tasted from so fitz
together for example soffin-chef
composed postinett update  an
julian so you can use list user
generated pattern is the generator patter  n
is nice because it can dynamic
liquid us civilist
the liszt is fix hefte like fix
tatmotorrad fix with the general wallpaper
institute implies rexhepi executed
the pipeline base compatriot container
part of the comic that is worte kollegah
something should be execution of one workflow
in distant
[Applause  ]